[Musique]
c'est tout le monde sait ce qu'ils y ont
se retrouvent aujourd'hui pour mon tout
premier tutorial
alors pourquoi j'en fais un bain parce
que suite à beaucoup de demandes
je décide aujourd'hui de faire un
tutoriel sur frappe ce que je veux
lancer tout de suite vais m'excuser pour
tous ces icônes un peu en bordel j'ai
jamais été un fan de la propreté
mondiaux
donc je laisse en bordel et je fais avec
un donc fraps donc frappe c'est un
logiciel tout d'abord bas payant
puisqu'avec la version d'essai on peut
filmer que 30 secondes
moi je vous cache pas que je ne vais pas
payer mais bon comme on dit google est
votre ami donc comme donc en fait donc
le but de ce tutoriel sera de vous
montrer comment faire pour se servir de
frappe mais surtout comment faire pour
ne pas léguer comme un taré
quand on est en jeu donc c'est assez
simple vous allez voir donc tout d'abord
j'ai la version 3.0.3 mais c'est pareil
pour toutes les versions au dessus de la
3.0 au dessus de cette version là quoi
donc ça on s'en fout un peu
vous pouvez décoché on s'en fout ça ça
revient au même
donc dans fps donc moi ça s'est hissée
mon disque dur externe
donc j'ai désactivé parce que je m'en
fous un peu hein on va être si vous
voulez ça sert à faire des fichiers pour
marquer l'évolution de vos fps dans le
jeu les variations du fps machin donc
frappe c'était un logiciel j'ai oublié
de dire un pour filmer
son écran aussi pour prendre des photos
et pour voir son nombre de fps donc donc
là vous mettez une touche donc par
exemple aller moi je met f5 belge
marketing fps et friendize mille max avg
bon j'ai jamais aimé chez même parce que
c'est le mettez l'eau sous les eaux vers
le hockey je ne sais pas trop ce qu
s'est assis je pense que c'est pour
enfin c'est en fait c'est pour
activer/désactiver la houle et enfin
pour si vous voulez quand vous lancez
fraps le nombre de fps s'affiche donc
soit on va gauche ici donc vous cochez 1
ce qui correspond soit à droite soit en
bas à droite en bas à gauche donc moi
j'ai mis un an à gauche parce que c'est
plus agréable et donc cette touche à mon
avis c'est pour afficher ou ne pas
afficher les fps donc ça vous cochez ça
si vous voulez hein c'est juste pour
donc s'actualise le nombre de fps tout
les une fois par seconde
parce que sinon ça fait une fois toutes
les milliardième de seconde et fps
variés à mort mais bon ça fait pas la
clé pour autant donc dans movie donc
c'est là l'étape la plus importante donc
je vous conseille d'enregistreurs vidéo
sur un disque dur externe pour disque
dur autre que le disque dur que vous
utilisez pour pour le jeu font pour
frappe moi par exemple j'ai fait mon
disque dur externe
donc voilà malpas porte mes vidéos donc
comme tout challenge à m m6 donc là la
très important 60 fps donc 60 fps si
vous voulez c'est le top 50 fps à un peu
moins bien et 30 fps bon bah c'est le
monde vient donc si vous voulez moi ce
que je vous conseille ce que c'est ce
que j'ai fais personnellement c'est de
tester tout d'abord à 30 fps
voyez si vous l'avez ou pas si vous
vouliez pas tranquille
vous pouvez mettre à 50 fps si vous la
gué et ben vous pouvez mettre par
exemple là vous vous mettez vous même à
connaître l'espèce vous voulez par
exemple 40
si vous l'aviez vous mettez 35 favola
vous essayez de mettre le maximum
possible sans lag et moi personnellement
je mets 60 puisque j'ai un pc plutôt
performant et je ne marque pas ensuite
si vous mettez en full size
c'est à dire que ça va filmer avec la
résolution de votre écran
par exemple moi je suis en 1920 1080 sa
film aura donc ans
1924 donc ça ça fait la guerre à mort
donc ma jument nappe size et c'est ce
que je vous conseille très fortement ce
qui permet de filmer à la moitié de
votre résolution est donc de palier du
tout quoi donc
ensuite avec la vidéo vous pouvez mettre
en hd dans sony vegas pro mais ça fait
pas un truc génial hein comme l'âge des
ppr qui coûte 200 euros
ça fait un truc quand même enfin potable
enfin même plus que potable mais géra
pas jusqu'à dire super mais voilà enfin
c'est plutôt agréable donc ensuite ça
c'est si vous voulez ou pas enregistrer
le son du pc
donc attention attention les amis quand
vous jouez sa enregistre aussi les sons
de tous les autres logiciels par exemple
si vous jouez que vous écoutez de la
musique en même temps massa enregistrera
le sont aussi de la musique
donc je vous conseille de ne pas aller
sur ce cadre de tout est activé du cc
leçon de jeu si vous voulez faire des
kilts gamme des choses comme ça avec le
son stéréo
ça c'est pour enregistrer votre micro
par exemple pour des vidéos en live moi
personnellement je coche ça ce qui fait
que ça enregistre aussi le son de mon
métro bon en l'occurrence un là je fume
pas avec frappe ce tutorat je filme avec
cam studio car fraps enregistre que dans
les jeux ou dans les animations flash
comme par exemple par exemple skype
pourrait sauver l'image d'un ami on peut
filmer ce stade c'est comme ça que j'ai
fait ma vidéo best-of sur skype dont
dont 5 audio et vidéo faut pas coché
parce qu'après l'eau john sac de 9 ans
willow jo ne sera pas synchronisés avec
la vidéo high maousse costaud ring vidéo
ça il ne faut pas coché ce évoluer sa
cache de curseur dans la vidéo bon quand
jo s'en fout hein ça cache
automatiquement et ça je ne sais pas ce
que c'est mais vous je vous conseille
pas de le cacher car j'ai jamais
personne jusqu'à présent le cocher
kenchop donc on va continuer on va
mettre accepte donc l'appareil a avoué
je prends jamais de screenshot donc
géminées dans photo avant mon jeu met
sur disque dur externe et cette heure
donc là vous choisissez le format de la
sortie une image
moi je mets jpg et voilà ça après et
puis voilà donc là si vous voulez
activer la répétition enfin si oui que
ça prenne inscrits automatiquement
toutes les x secondes vous cochez et ça
je ne peux donc voilà donc et j'espère
que structurel vous aura bien aidé je
vous invite à acheter fraps ou à vous
procurer d'une manière ou d'une autre je
peux pas savoir hier donc voilà bah
écoute et j'espère que vous aurez des
comme ça vous pouvez faire des parties
commentées vous lancer sur youtube comme
je lé fais et puis vous éclater à tenter
dé 3,6 de la mort de scoop en filmant
voila voila merci tout le monde des
saluts